hello everybody
hope you are having a great evening
here in san luis it's a little bit rainy
it was unexpected and it was kind of the
last day of semester i guess
because everybody are going home for
thanksgiving and they're not supposed to
come back
um but it's like it's it's kind of a
weird um
mixture because like i'm gonna be here
and i know
a lot of other people are here for the
next two months but
we'd have to like get through the finals
and yeah it's gonna be some
fun stuff i like the ghost campus nobody
around
less chances of getting coveted
all right so um besides my very
uh very interesting campus
events going on i uh i was
i kind of stumbled upon these two uh
this bunch of like
french games and i really really wanted
to show
them because um in process of selecting
games for
my upcoming book that i'm writing with
my brother we
really um just like i don't want to show
the games like we're selecting but at
the same time the ones that
we kind of want to show but we can't
show because it doesn't really fit
anywhere
i decided to give those a try so
um ah here is tracing in the chat
oh thank you yaroslav gmt is fine
he is kind of just chilling on gabby's
lap right now
so i think i don't know if we're going
to get an appearance from jampishi
easily to chill right now
i am writing the chess book yeah um
i'm writing it with the help of my
brother he is mainly the
muscle behind it he he has a lot of free
time
so he's helping me a lot with it so
we're doing
um like 50 50 type of partnership
that should be fun yeah um
so for today the first game i decided to
leave the
the names under um so if you
to just have an idea of whose game
you're watching you would have that
choice because
sometimes i really want to know who uh
whose game am i watching
so all right let's go ahead and get
started
yeah mighty french so uh as
you are mostly as most of you are
probably aware of
dominguez has switched to federation to
us i think it hit about
two years ago if i'm not mistaken and um
at least he was he was playing for us at
least 2019 that i know for sure
but the years have been really flying by
for me so
i might have my ears a little up and
down but
he's a great chess player very great guy
but
um talia can tell you all about him
there
i believe country mates that's what he
would say
anyways um i really enjoy watching his
games he's such a great chess player so
um the first game is one of the games
that he played
um i actually don't
know when he played this game i think
this was yeah this is 2012
yeah but i
i wish i had more context about when
like
where why when of the game um
so my guess is simply since this was the
russian um
thing it was in russia what was in
russia in 2012
oh my god 2012 i was such a baby it was
14.
oh okay so oh that is and that's what i
wanted to click on
so let's just keep looking at this
french
um i did want to ask a quick question on
who
here plays this advanced variation with
e5
so what do you guys think who plays this
i used to play it i played occasionally
on blitz and
like rapid games but i kind of started
growing um
like the nice c3 line grew more on me
so um
i don't really have a doubt that magnus
will crush me in a blindfold game i
don't i mean maybe if you play 100 games
i might
have better chance but um
oh my gosh real crushed i think everyone
or all of us combined here
so there are 46 people at the moment
oh it's combined
all right um i i think this e5 like
it's such a great positional masterpiece
but
at the same time you kind of have to be
very careful because
it's positional but at the same time it
has a lot of dynamic um
ideas all right
so knight c6 normal stop knight f3
iu7 we got to get the pieces out so
knight a3 is something that i actually
tried a few times because well your idea
is kind of with this knight c2 but when
i played this line i really like his
ideas with like a3 b4 so that was kind
of my main line
so what do you guys think would you
prefer knight a3 or a3
or white what do you think would be a
better um
better roots to take rounds to take i
feel like i mean i really do like this
a32
um so
i mean i i don't know i
[Music]
i think it really depends on what you're
doing and what your opponent
is doing because if knight knight d7 if
queen b6
then a3 is i think a little bit more uh
popular
because then this b4 is coming you got
to get this bishop to b2 you got to do
like chop chop chop
and you can't really they don't really
have that luxury of playing knight a3
even though it could go fine but take
take and then check
and yeah it doesn't really feel as
as appealing i want to say
so even okay so knight e7 knight a3
take we got to take it and let's see two
pretty much only logical move because
bishop e3 we don't really want to give
that choice
and now uh why is tim
what do you think we should do
oh something yours was saying
uh yeah that 92 i gave it a few tries
but it's kind of
i don't think it was for me um i
really do like playing against french
and i've had such good score
playing against french recently and just
alter out i think it's one of those
positions that i just
i get it i don't know how to how else to
tell it
and it kind of like goes with my style
but um
so if you remember two of my us
championship games where
against french and i won both of them
and it was just like
really interesting games very dynamic
and i
kind of my opponents just really um
i don't want to say made it easy for me
but the position was really my style
didn't really have much to
worry about they didn't really give me a
hard time at least
what is my book about so it's uh it's
something
we're still working on the exact title
but the
um content of it is how the
uh some like basically a lot of the
things that i was talking
in our streams since basically january
um that how but
higher rated opponents managed to save a
worse position
or how when you're a little lower-rated
uh opponent how you managed to actually
succeed and win the game so it's a lot
about those
uh it has a lot of psychology embedded
in it it has a lot of
um great games from me my brother and
a lot of the really high uh rating chess
players
so i think it's gonna be a good one
we're still working on it so it's still
working process but
[Music]
should be published hopefully early next
year
it is about chess yeah it has a lot of
chess analysis just positions
openings everything in it we are kind of
shooting for two volumes
but if it's i mean if we can fit it all
in one book why not
so i don't really know about bishop d2 i
don't really want to give up this pawn
um a3 was a suggestion
i i don't like a3 a3 would i do b4
bishop b2
i i would do this yeah bishop d3 thank
you
matty yeah bishop d3
so the idea of bishop d3 is well you
can't really take over here
because that will just be a blender
at the end there is this bishop b5 right
and your clean drops
oh that's a little too far so you can't
really do that
so bishop d3 is like a safe move
basically
and you're getting uh getting yourself
getting your king in a safe place as
well
bishop d7 obviously stopping these ideas
of bishop b5
um black could actually play bishop b4
check now my question to you what should
you do after bishop b4
check
yeah i can get one um the thing is if
you were to play bishop d2
um it's doable but it's not as desired
because take you take with queen b2 is a
little bit weak
take castle queen can just run away
i mean it's doable but i wouldn't
exactly recommend it
um what about take should we take it
twin is most likely gonna take
uh yeah shock i've seen that idea before
i
faced it a bunch of times much earlier
in my chest career and
king of one is actually a good idea so i
kind of just wanted to touch
a little on this idea with um
knight takes b4 but i
i don't really feel comfortable giving
up so many palms
so that's something i probably wouldn't
go for
g4 oh what about not g4 what about
something trying to be trapped to queen
i like trapping queens could maybe go to
c5 stop
castling i mean i kind of like it but at
the same time i don't
feel as comfortable so if this happened
to me in the game i would definitely
play
um king f1 and
i would simply follow it to the either
g4 or simply g3
i could always just bring up the rook to
h3 too i've done a game like that
yeah so tracy is a french hater um
i've realized that for a long time
it's a problem she needs to get some
counseling for
she hates french can't stand french she
sees french
she gets a mental breakdown i'm messing
with you no
just doesn't like it i don't think it's
that strong
ah but yeah i have to mess with tracy
it's like a
rule of thumb every tuesday and friday i
get to mess with tracy for about 30
seconds
but if anything more than that then i
she'll roast me really bad so i i i'll
keep it
under control all right so yeah
um king f1 i i i i like the idea if
but if you play something bishop seven
i'll just push and i believe this was a
game that
um was played between short and
um but
i don't this i mean i don't think you
have to play it like this you can't
if you want to and oh this f4 square
looks so nice if i could just play like
h4 i don't like that though
but you get the idea if you could just
like to turn the queen to d3 play an h4
or something
yeah but yes king f1 is the better idea
so how anyways in the game uh
bishop d7 was played castle
and now um i think my main question is
can black take it what if knight takes
d4
what do you think we would do as whites
because we don't really have that check
at the end anymore so
yeah while you're thinking i'm gonna go
ahead and do the weekly went
um uh so
this is the finals week for me i don't
really have any
traditional exams i have i have a
take-home exam
which is so hard i haven't been able to
answer even one question so far
and i have nine papers oh my god
so many papers so i'm working on one of
them
and yeah i'm writing about just organ
donation and
addiction and it's it's it's very
challenging it's it can get
really dark really fast so if there are
any
i mean healthcare providers or anyone
healthcare related here and you want to
give me some advice on how to
deal with the organ donation darkness
i would much appreciate that if not
chess is fine too it just helps
but yeah um so knight days d4
i haven't actually gotten any uh answers
on why not to do 964.
oh you hate playing against french i
mean i used to hate playing games french
but then i
i somehow started getting really good
scores and just
in over the years i don't think we
should take on f5 because you take on f5
knight takes on f5 and he just ate your
pawn so it doesn't really make any sense
so um sorry that was the main line but
if take
what if we just take it back and
do this pen this makes sense right
i like pins thank you exactly this
should be three we have bishop c5 just
b4
take over here i'll take that attack
your queen and i'll pick this up it's
just a
healthy piece yeah this wasn't too hard
all right so what about a5 so
the purpose of this a5 is you remember
how in
this line after bishop c5 there was this
b4
so if you played a5 now at the end of
that line you wouldn't
face b4 so basically this
a5 is a preparation to take knight takes
d4
so now you have to determine uh can you
save this pawn and
uh well how do you want to save this
pawn
so yeah that's kind of
where we are at right now
i've also developed a taste for green
tea matcha
called unsweetened but
yeah it feels a little weird to drink
green stuff
but i like shrek growing up so
i guess i'm not this is actually
sherry green oh god
so
oh can't hear
yeah i think we should go for bishop
five
yeah take and then knight knight e392 is
very strong
uh the idea is if you can't occupy this
f5 f4 square
is going to be perfect so when bishop e6
your goal is kind of to figure out and
put a knight on f4
and that is something that i believe i'm
probably
saw earlier
so shock that i don't understand this
either
i feel like i just developed a good
feeling for it
over the years i don't think there is
like a way to understand
french you just kind of like
get a feeling on this position my
knights would prevent but my knights
could benefit
being on for example f4 right now and
then you just kind of try to
figure out the route and the route
on how to get it there
so yeah exactly g3 should be good enough
g3 um in the game i played bishop e7
uh dominguez played knight g2
and now the thing is if you play knight
f4 they're gonna be g5s so
how do we prevent this ah hello from
egypt
lovely i always wanted to visit egypt
so how do we stop this g5 any
[Music]
suggestions
oh the cap is up there huh
cat's making a small appearance
with his tail
it's raining outside so he's kind of
watching and yes thank you one two three
bunch of fours h4
um you kind of just stopped g5 and
cast those you get your knights onto the
f4 black plays rook c8s now
so in this position it's very important
to actually be able to follow it up
because
this is the position that you know you
are doing a bit better than your
opponent
but you need to have a plan and
you have to be able to follow that plan
and build up on that plan
so if you can't find what you're doing
and if you just kind of
um play some just just moves that don't
flow together then you're gonna get in
really hot waters really fast
so that is like this
is one of the positions that i would
potentially include in the upcoming book
i haven't
but that's like these are the type of
positions that i would like to talk
about
and okay i know i'm a bit better but now
what
that's kind of the that's something that
i that i struggled with a lot
in my chest carrier i still do but i
think it has gotten a lot better over
the years
so yeah white to move
what's the plan what are you trying to
achieve and
how do you plan to do that
i don't think it's too hard to suggest
that okay i'm probably going to be doing
something in the king side
and my black is going to probably be
doing something in the queen side
so we we kind of know that already but
how
that the how is the big question what am
i drinking
green tea matcha feels a little weird
saying it out loud but it's kind of
tasty actually
thank you thank you thank you um
pie penchak that is actually very
accurate
yeah we are kind of planning on um
attacking in the queen in the king side
but the opponent is also going to be
attacking in the king side the queen
side so you can i mean
you kind of have to make that choice am
i going to completely ignore the queen
side
or am i going to actually do something
in
um to to just prepare a little better
for my pink side queen size so many
kings of queens
i don't i mean i don't think you're
there's anything to sacrifice right now
it's more about just um where are you
going to place your pieces
type of deal and you see i think
one of the biggest problems and what
these challenges right
now is how are you going to use the
stroke because you can't just
exactly move this bishop you're going to
drop the pawn and you shouldn't you
don't
really want to do that so you can't
really push this pawn because then
you're giving your opponent a
target to go after so
so i agree that we should do something
in the king side i
agree that uh the ideas with h5 and
knight h4
do seem very appealing but we kind of
have to prepare for it better
and no we can't just exactly go around
and play this a4 because then
c7 or c8 and black gets a very
fast on this attack
so
a4 could be interesting but for k3 on uh
k3 unfortunately does not work this guy
is just going to take that away
so how else can you
defend b2 what about turkey one you
could try to go to e2 and defend it
free the bishop to get the queen on the
other side
i think that would be an interesting
idea what do you guys think about rookie
one
foreign
i agree rookie one does look better than
rugby one
ah i see is peachy sleeping huh
oh he's actually being super cute yeah
i don't wanna go squeeze the cabinet
which is the cheek is hanging down
i don't know if you guys have a visual
on it or not but
yeah ah
i mean
oh my chat that's weird just a second
let me reload this page actually
i gotta reload my youtube oh lovely
okay better sorry my chats got a little
weird for a second
yeah so i'm glad that do you guys like
the idea of rookie one
so let's continue uh rookie one we wanna
go
rookie two defend b2 free the bishop
open the queen
so that's what i meant by trying to
figure out what exactly to do
because another way of thinking about it
your opponent
black obviously knows that you're going
to do stuff in the kingside
and black obviously knows that you know
that he's gonna do stuff in the kings
in a queen side so that's not the trick
the trick is how to hold your queen sign
and attack black's king side so that's
why we want to play this tricky one
so we're gonna put the stroke on e2 and
defend our second rank
while we get the chance to kind of like
swift the queen to the other side
all right jerky one rook c7 rookie two
defending the pawn
there get the bishop up bishop defending
the
the pawn now um you could potentially
want to move this knight and maneuver it
around
there was a suggestion of h5 knight h4
we're going to take a look at it but
even if not that's you could just try to
um reroute the knight to
somewhere in the center maybe queen side
to defend it a little bit better
what if f6 huh um you have to be very
careful
the your bishop is under attack so f6
i would really love that oh hi steve
north
alright so um knight b4
now this is actually a very critical
position
that it um it would be very very
interesting if you could
find the right move so
what do you guys think
is d5 awakens yep kind of
oh i'm glad you beat a 1900 player
that's actually pretty great
um so far my schoolwork has been great i
have all a's but it's just
such a huge load and yeah
it's it's just
a lot to do and i have like one more
week of school left
basically so
actually a little bit more until next
thursday so
but still 91 yeah whoa
very impressed thank you guys that was a
very great suggestion
you could potentially consider taking on
e6
but i wouldn't recommend it yet
uh because i mean take knight e1 you
would still have to do
this you shouldn't really give up the c4
or c2 square you don't really want to
have to deal with those
later on actually and it's it just feels
like you would be giving
your um giving your opponent too many
chances and this mic is better on a
fourth and off the board
so i don't really like 96 but knight t1
i'm all for it
now queen b5 now what
uh justin just to mention if your
opponent were to play g5 yeah you can
take it
take over that and kick that knight away
and then you would have f4
this would be an ideal position because
if you were to play g4
now the rook is ready to jump the king
could just move away and you could start
tripling stuff in the h file way faster
than your opponent to it
and because you still have this knight
you could try to play
both sides i put down d3 put it on c2 it
would be
very very pleasant so
just wanted to mention the the idea
about g5
but with queen b5 oh thank you shock
that is a very nice
that's very nice of you we could
consider
a3 uh a3 the knight
i'm probably going to go back to either
c6 or a6 so
those are the two logical places to go
um
if you want to keep your knight on the
board but
i mean the thing is if a3 um i
i don't really know what's the next move
that i would do as white
let's say you would play knight c6
can i play or should i open
do i want truck c1
do i want group c2 or i could just
ignore those whole things and just play
knight d3
so a lot of things to think about
but i do like the idea of a3 let's say
knight goes to a6 now what where do you
think you should place your knights
i think you could potentially consider
maybe starting to move the king
not exactly right away but the idea is
there so you're preparing
to move your stuff but i don't think
it's the right time so i kind of think
it's
better to just push this knight to d3
and your knight is great on d3 is
supported by the other knight
you might want to take and play the
other knight to f4 again
huge mice really depends on the position
um
now you could start considering bringing
your pieces to the other side
this knight is defending the pawn it's
defending the c1 square
i really do like this lines on d3
exactly yeah that's a very good thing to
say ideas are one thing execution is
another
so knight d3 opponents played a4
now why to move what do you think we
should do
and the a4 was not the most accurate
move
and white does have a slight advantage
now
before that it was just like a
like a better feeling than the position
it wasn't like a real advantage but now
it's kind of a real advantage
like before that it was like point three
so it doesn't really count
now it's more like point seven point
eight for
my for those who want to know more about
the material behind it oh
um actually nice e6
it's interesting but not the
not right now so the thing is we want to
provoke g5 as much as possible
so if we were to take it and then play
knight f4
just queen goes to d7 who is defending
it yeah you add this cool knight g6
but then you could try b3 so you could
like play in both sides
but it's still like you still it would
be nice if you were a little bit more
prepared for
knight takes e6
oh the cat just passed
oh she's being shook for gabby
i want my cat
he's a little scared of rain
ah can you do it could be useful
um this move might be a little too hard
for you guys
to be honest but i
it it was hard for me to uh see it at
first
as well but it's a very logical move
like thank you whoa one two three four
yeah rick d2 you're trying to open up
your clean
you might not want to do it right now
you might want to just like play g4 or
something
but you're at least giving yourself the
opportunity and your rook on e2
was kind of blocking the queen so you
just move it and you open it
um in the game i played bishop f8
uh black could consider something like
her c4
and just like tank and then g4 this this
was another way to go
so in the game bishop f8
now is it time to play g4
when was this game played i believe 2012
so what do you guys think is it time to
play just g4
um knight e6 we could do 96 and then g4
but the thing is i don't know if i want
to play this knight g6
the knight takes e6 anytime soon so
if you're gonna do knight takes e6 and
then g4 why not g4 now
challenging the c file would be actually
very powerful
ah yarista that is actually a very very
good point
no i think the knight on d3 is okay no
nobody's going anywhere with that knight
on d3
so g4 actually you're not losing a pawn
because take you can always take and
then just take it back with the queen
and that's kind of what we want we want
this
we want this type of position we want
the queen to get to g4 because then we
are tagging over there
knight f4 could come um the king can
just swing and the rook can come so
it's a lot of good possibilities for
white so we want to get that queen to g4
so that's kind of why g4 is best first
exactly can because we if you don't take
it
i'm gonna play g5 yeah
great great contribution everybody
um
grade 12 that is actually a very fair
point a4 was
not a mistake the position was already
worse
so black could try to like bring the
queen back and just try to
push a little bit try to get something
like that happening maybe with queen to
d7
um that's another thing that i could
have done but yes i agree a4 was not a
mistake by itself but a4
after a4 white had just kind of a easier
plan
easier way to deal with this all right
so g4
um if queen d7 then we would do g5
and now this is just the easy way to win
right we're just going to get the coin
to the h file
and um just easily win this basically
just all
bring all the increases to each one how
about
bishop to d7
but what do you think we should do now
logo and steven thank you that was
actually funny i enjoyed this
yeah g5 place about time let's go g5
um g5 now actually
i think g6 is one of the things that we
would have to consider
because if you if you took it i mean why
this is still much better but you would
still have to
accurately get your queen out so i think
that's the only trick
um what if just take
oh sorry g6 actually queen f3 is a
little bit better
and then you could take and then try and
get into as much as weakness as possible
also try to pick up some pieces but a g5
take what now
um i'm assuming everybody wants to take
it back
now g6 now what is our game plan whoa
yep queen x3 and after queen f3
um
we're simply gonna like triple stuff up
on
um a tree and just get mates right i
don't think that's there's much
much else to it just bring the rook
bring the other rook
and just i think this is actually
the one of the easiest mates in history
even if you try to run with your king
just rick h7 yeah i'll take that and
i'll bring the other knights oh my god
this is such a beautiful position
uh you could try with drug h4 queen d7
bring up the rook
queen d8 ah slowly slowly now
why wouldn't we go to queen s3 just
checking your sharpness why would you
have to play this queen
g3 first
what does our opponent want to do with
that queen on d8
exactly it's attacking g5 so we're just
gonna simply
defend it and slowly
slowly put that truck in there and
you're gonna go queenish four
so yeah you're kind of making your
opponents miserable and
it's actually giving up mates while
you're doing that so it's a lot of fun
right
um yeah this is the first game i wanted
to show you
and i also want to show you a game that
i played when i was a baby
and when i say baby i mean this was when
2013 actually
i thought this was before that so
um i'm gonna probably brace through this
game but
it was very interesting because i think
this was actually
um i was playing one of the this was an
asian championship 2013
but i was playing one of the girls from
my
uh category so this was like an iranian
girl that i was playing
same category same age i think i think
she was a year older i don't
exactly remember but um i played with
her
a bunch of times so um
yeah i remember one of the games was
really funny because she had a better
position but she
blundered her queen and i absolutely
love that
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna um not gonna
sit here and say i don't like
queen blenders yeah um
i was 15 in 2013 it feels like a baby
now but when i was 15
i felt like i was at the top of the
world i was such an adult i knew what i
was doing all those fun things
so yeah um
yeah but actually fun fact i did win
asian championship 20 12
13 and 14 and then i just stopped
playing it because
i think three times getting goals an
asian youth championship was enough i
think
yeah so oh my god you're 15. no way
you sound way more mature so okay i
really want to show this game so i'm
gonna um
just gonna go faster but
yeah uh this was one of those games that
obviously i prepared for and i knew what
i was doing in the opening
but uh as as i mentioned this in the
previous game that i was talking about
we kind of i kind of really like this
idea of
just i'm playing against french with
this a3 v4 so i gave it a try
knight c3 knight f5 bam
you gotta move the queen a bishop b2
defending your
pawn then the knight c5s are also coming
up sometime
soon and this
is the type of position that we talked
about a little bit earlier just
not exactly but the the idea of it
f4 square is weak i wish i had a knight
in there ah this side is a little bit
annoying so i'm probably going to take
it
i really want to have this h4 so it's
just a matter of which one to do first
so i ended up doing h4 first h5 and at
this point i was like
yeah i gotta take that knight and i did
take back and now why is to move what do
you actually think it's a good move
the move i did was kind of questionable
but i really liked it
so what do you think oh we have a 12
year old in the chat
ah very interesting i did not think that
i mean this is a very family friendly
stream so
you're welcome but i
i hadn't i always thought like oh maybe
it was twitch that under 13 you can't
join i i don't exactly know about the
rules so
as long as you're following them you're
fine you're more than welcome
um i wouldn't recommend castling
actually castling is fun
but i wouldn't do it unless like i
really had to
castline is doable there's nothing like
fundamentally wrong with it but
let me ask you a question which piece of
yours
is playing kind of useless right now
which piece can you improve
i see some ideas with jersey one knight
c5s
uh-huh
uh rook h3 maybe or c1 maybe but
i really hated how much my bishop here
was useless
it's just defending something that's not
even being really attacked
so in the game i played bishop c1 which
was actually not a good idea
the idea was good the move itself was
wrong because now black has a5
and black would be able to kind of mess
with my structure over there
if i played b5 they would be like a
knight a7 b6 queen c6 and
i would give my opponent a little too
much chance on
um making it really hard for me to
keep my advantage whereas here i
actually have
a pretty decent advantage but something
like rook c1 would be much more
um understandable
and then i could potentially look into
moving the might
but in the game this bishop was really
bugging me and i really wanted to try
and place it on f6
i don't really know why
yeah i think something like bishop c1
would be very
pleasant in a few move not right away
but she played my knight e7 bishop g5
uh she took i think bishop d5 would have
been more annoying
the same way that my bishop is bothering
your king your bishop should be
bothering my king that's kind of just
my life philosophy but take
take and now
um you kind of have only two choices
right the queen beats your queen d1
which one do you think you should do
or the better which one do you think i
did
yeah arya and i agree visual c1 could be
effective in a lot of french because
that's my
like that's supposedly my bad bishop but
right now on g5 it looks pretty good to
me
so
um my problem was if i played queen v3
there would be a queen c4 and i didn't
really want to deal with that
um so i went to playing d1
my my thought process was well if you
give me queen c3
i'll just play king upon and then later
g3 king g2 i'm safe
nobody was really attacking me um
ah surprise there slowly played queen d1
so queen d1 and she played knight
g8 again this was a game between two
kids
i was like two my l rating was
2040 her rating was like 1800 so it's
not like a super quality game
but uh i just really i i do
like to look at um how far i come
and just look at my games from when i
was a baby
and it's kind of nice to just see those
so knight's g8 what do you guys think
about that i mean obviously sonic big
move
but what do you think white should do
yeah
rook c1 i think knight g8 was just to
stop this bishop
um f6 idea but i wasn't really planning
on playing at that bishop of six i mean
show six is nice but it's not
like magic queen d7
now how are we going to develop
and i'm setting up for next game i mean
at this rate
uh it is like it's plus two already but
you still have to play accurately
so one thing that i wish i did and
i didn't do was just my d2 knight b3 and
then i could just try to go around there
but in the game i played drug h3
my idea was well i'm not gonna castle so
i might as well play this rook history i
could try to get to c3
we'll see that was kind of my thought
process
um like okay it's not like a bulletproof
one but
i kind of liked it
so she played bishop e7
now i go 92 now the fun thing is if you
were to take take first of all this pawn
is
under some pressure
second of all your c5 square is
like it's gonna be very painful i
didn't want to castle because i felt
that my king was safe in the center
which was actually a wise decision i
could have tried king f1 king g1 if
needed
but i thought my rook on h file would be
more useful than
f1 at least at the moment and that
that was a that was a good decision i
stand by it
um i like 92 she played f6
now f6 should we take it
i think we should take it right because
uh when you take that
now i can still um kind of ignore it
and play knight b3 again if you take
this i'll take back
and whoa this should not move like that
and then i set up my c5 i still have
these all
stuff happening to you so shipment king
f7
i slowly played rook c3 my threat is
very clear
bishop d8 defending that knight c5
going after the weak spots weak squares
clean now why do
what do you think we should do your
position is super winning
so just try to find that the most
logical moves that you
think you should do
why should you take the bishop and not
the night
huh uh i'm annie do you have a
position that you are thinking about
because i can't think of exactly where
queen e2 exactly technically knight e6
tactic
would also work but i
i mean it's a very lovely tactic but
i didn't feel the need to do that and 32
worked just perfectly fine queen b6
now knight d7 i might want to just
jump again the other way uh
check rook c6
and uh in the game i believe
she just played bishop fixed g5 and i
took on d6 and she just resigned here
which is also matin uh
six moves yeah
because you move the king there's
neither seven actually let's show it
make the king of six knight f7
king g7 or anywhere basically knight g5
and yeah this is mates right you move
the king or herself
and then queen of six
she tried to go this gambit uh i don't
think so i think it was
i mean i think it was kind of forced
honestly after rick c6 like what are you
gonna do with your queen
if you play queen to f8 i'm just simply
gonna take over here
and this is still pretty lost with all
the things that are happening
to your king so yeah
uh i really enjoyed these two games like
i think i
could have done um slightly better on
the second on the game that i played but
the game with dominguez did was very
lovely
i think i did a um like a
mini version of a great game what was my
racing back then
i had this the the number in front of
this number that you see was my rating
in 2015 the 2013. by 2015 i
had about 300 more than that
actually more 250 more than that so i
jumped a lot
but yeah uh i hope you guys enjoyed this
um
it was i i really did i really love
teaching french i really like
talking about it it's just one of those
openings that i just kind of
get um but like if you show me some
caracon i might as well be like ooh
so i mean i can't play against it but i
won't be like yes my phone played carol
come and find my planet floyd's
like yes so uh
until that change i'm gonna be very
happy about it
and yeah all right i hope you guys
enjoyed it
uh i will not see you until the
thanksgiving so if you are celebrating
thanksgiving
happy thanksgiving it's about two days
away
so in two days but in about 48 hours
we're all gonna be
laying down belly up with full turkey i
guess
but um i will say on friday so make sure
to
to be back on friday for our tweet
channel and
hopefully the turkey has digested by
then
and i'm gonna go deal with my mind
school papers
due on over the weekend all right um
i had a very lovely evening i hope you
guys enjoyed it too
i did not have a visual on the cats but
you know
you know he's always around so um
have a great rest of your evening and
i'll see you on friday
bye